how many companies have you interacted
with today well you got up in the
morning took a shower wash the hair just
a hair dryer net breakfast eight cereals
fruit yogurt whatever had coffee tea you
took public transfer to come here or
maybe used to your private car you
interacted with the company that you
work for or that you owned you
interacted with your clients your
customers and so on and so forth I'm
pretty sure there are at least seven
companies you have interacted with today
let me tell you a stunning statistic one
out of seven large public corporations
commits fraud every year this is a u.s.
academic study that looks at US
companies I have no reason to believe
that's different in Europe this is a
study that looks at both detected and
undetected fraud using statistical
methods this is not petty fraud these
frauds cost the shareholders of these
companies and therefore society on the
order of three hundred and eighty
billion dollars per year we can all
think of some examples right the car
industry's secrets aren't quite so
secret anymore fraud has become a
feature not a bug of the financial
services industry that's not me who's
claiming that that's the president of
the American Finance Association who
stated that in his presidential address
that's a huge problem if you think about
especially an economy like Switzerland
which relies so much on the trust put
into its financial industry on the other
hand there are six out of seven
companies who actually remain honest
despite all temptations to start
engaging in fraud there are
whistleblowers like Michael Woodford who
blew the whistle on Olympus these
whistleblowers risk their careers their
friendships to bring out the truth about
their companies there are journalists
like Anna Politkovskaya who risk even
to report human rights violations she
got killed every year around hundred
journalists get killed because of their
conviction to bring out the truth so in
my talk today I want to share with you
some insights I've obtained and learned
in the last 10 years of conducting
research on this I'm a researcher
scientist working with economists
financial economists ethicists
neuroscientists lawyers and others
trying to understand what makes humans
tick and how can we address this issue
of fraud in corporations and therefore
contribute to the improvement of the
world I want to start by sharing with
you two very distinct visions of how
people beings first meet Adam Smith
founding father of modern economics his
basic idea was that if everybody behaves
in their own self-interest that's good
for everybody in the end self-interest
isn't a merrily defined concept just for
your immediate utility it has a long
around implication let's think about
that think about this dog here that
might be us right there's this
temptation I apologize to all
vegetarians but you know dogs do like
the bratwurst now
the straight-up self-interested move
here is to go for that so my friend Adam
here might jump up get the sausage and
thereby ruining all this beautiful
tableware
but that's not what Adam Smith meant he
didn't mean disregard all consequences
to the contrary he would have thought
well there may be negative consequences
for example the owner might be angry
with the dog and the dog anticipating
that might not behave in this way right
that might be us weighing the benefits
and costs of our actions how does that
play out well many of you I'm sure have
in your companies especially if it's a
large company a code of conduct and then
if you behave according to that code of
conduct that improves your chances of
getting a bonus payment and on the other
hand if you disregard it then there are
higher chances of not getting you
or it's being diminished in other words
this is a very economic motivation of
trying to get people to be more honest
or more aligned with the corporation's
principles
similarly reputation is a very powerful
economic force right we try to build a
reputation maybe for being honest
because then people trust us more in the
future right Adam Smith talked about the
Baker who is not producing good bread
out of his benevolence for those people
who consume the bread but because he
wants to sell more future bread in my
research we find for example at the
University of Zurich that Swiss banks
who get caught up in media and in the
context for example of tax evasion of
tax fraud have bad media coverage they
lose net new money in the future and
therefore making lower profits that's a
very powerful reputational force
benefits and costs here's another
viewpoint of the world meet Immanuel
Kant 18th century German philosopher
superstar he developed this notion that
independent of the consequences some
actions are just right and some are just
wrong it's just wrong to lie for example
so meet my friend emmanuel here he knows
he had a sausage is very tasty but he's
gonna turn away because he's a good dog
he knows it's wrong to jump up and risk
ruining all this beautiful tableware if
you believe that people are motivated
like that then all this stuff about
incentives all this stuff about code of
conduct and bonus systems and so on
doesn't make a whole lot of sense that
people are motivated by different values
perhaps so what are people actually
motivated by these two gentlemen here
have perfect hairdo but they give us
very different views of the world what
do we do with this well I'm an economist
and we conduct so-called experiments to
address this issue we strip away facts
which are confusing in real
the reality is so rich there's so much
going on it's almost impossible to know
what drives people's behavior really so
let's do a little experiment together
imagine the following situation you're
in a room alone
not like here there's a five franc coin
like the one I'm holding up right now in
front of you here are your instructions
toss the coin four times and then on a
computer terminal in front of you enter
the number of times
tails came up this is the situation
here's the rub for every time you
announce that you had a tails throw you
get paid five francs so if you say I had
two tails froze you get paid ten francs
if you say you had zero you get paid
zero friends if you say I had four tails
throws then you get paid 20 francs it's
anonymous nobody's watching what you're
doing and you get paid that money
anonymously I got two questions for you
you know what's coming out right first
how would you behave in that situation
the second look to your left and look to
your right and think about how the
person sitting next to you might behave
in that situation we did this experiment
for real we did it at the Manifesta art
exhibition that took place here in
zurich recently not with students in the
lab at the university but with the real
population like you guys first a quick
reminder of stats if I throw the coin
four times and it's a fair coin then the
probability that it comes up four times
tails is six point twenty five percent
and I hope you can intuitively see that
the probability that all four of them
are tails is much lower than two of them
are tails right here are the specific
numbers here's what happened people did
this experiment for real around thirty
to thirty five percent of people said
well I had four tails throws that's
extremely unlikely but the really
amazing thing here perhaps to an
economist is there are around 65 percent
of people who did not say I have four
tails throws even though in that
situation nobody's watching you the only
consequence that's in place is you get
more money if you say four then less you
leave twenty francs on the table by
announcing maybe zero I don't know
whether the people the other people over
honest or whether they also said a
little bit higher or lower than what
they did because it's anonymous we only
observe the distribution but what I can
tell you and here is another coin toss
there you go it's tails all right
but don't don't check okay but I can
tell you is that not everybody behaved
like Adam Smith would have predicted
that so what does that leave us with
well it seems people are motivated by
certain intrinsic values and in our
research we look at this we look at the
idea that people have so-called
protected values a protected value isn't
just any value and protected value is a
value where you're willing to pay a
price to uphold that value are willing
to pay a price to withstand the
temptation to give in and the
consequence is you feel better if you
earn money in a way that's consistent
with your values let me show you this
again in the metaphor of our beloved dog
here if we succeed in getting the
sausage without violating our values
then the sausage tastes better that's
what our research shows if on the other
hand we do so if we get the sausage and
in doing so we actually violate values
we value the sausage less quantitatively
that's quite powerful we can measure
these protected values for example by a
survey measure simple 9 item survey
that's quite predictive in these
experiments if you think about the
average of the population and then
there's a distribution around that
people are different we all are
different people who have a set of
protected values that's one standard
deviation above the average they
discount money they receive by lying by
about 25% that means a dollar received
when lying is worth to them only 75
cents without any incentives you put in
place for them to behave honestly it's
their intrinsic motivation by the way
I'm not a moral authority I'm not saying
I have all these beautiful values right
but I'm interested in how people behave
in how we can leverage that richness in
human nature to actually improve the
workings of our organized
so there are two very very different
visions here on the one hand you can
appeal to benefits and costs and try to
get people to behave according to them
on the other hand you can select people
who have the values and the desirable
characteristics of course competencies
that go in line with your organization I
do not yet know where these protected
values really come from is it nurture or
is it nature what I can tell you is that
the distribution looks pretty similar
for men and women it looks pretty
similar for those who had studied
economics or those who had studied
psychology it looks even pretty civil
around different age categories among
adults but I don't know yet how this
develops over a lifetime that will be
the subject of future research the idea
I want to leave you with is it's all
right to appeal to incentives I'm an
economist I certainly believe in the
fact that incentives work but do you
think about selecting the right people
rather than having people and then
putting incentives in place
selecting the right people with the
right values may go a long way to saving
a lot of trouble and a lot of money in
your organizations in other words it
will pay off to put people first thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]